so how are you all doing today
you're day two
while we're getting the last little
thing set up on the AV side how many are
first time strange lovers here
oh wow look at all the hands welcome
welcome much like the keynote yesterday
uh I was on my strange first stranger
was also in 2017 and I I've also been
obsessively talking about it since then
in fact there are several people who I
twisted the arms of to come this year uh
in this room right now so before we get
started on my talk I'd love for a stick
of a round of applause to Alex and the
team for like over 10 years of running
an amazing event
thank you
it's it's always been the highlight of
my my uh Year and I hope it it so far
it's continued to be but like enough
about them let's talk about me
my name is Marianne belotti I wrote this
book called killed with fire about
modernizing Legacy systems that's by and
large what I spent most of my time doing
looking at really really old really
broken nasty computer systems and
figuring out and make them slightly less
nasty and less broken
um depending on whether you count the
packing I did when I was 13 years old
I've been sort of programming for 20
plus years and right now I spent a lot
of my time independent doing consulting
and a lot of corporate training actually
on how people reason about how Engineers
specifically reason about systems and
model systems and things like that
and so these are
these are when you do my kind of job you
hear a lot
I hear alarmingly often we have this
server no one knows what's on it no one
knows what it does we're afraid to turn
it off
I also hear far too often there's this
one guy that knows how this code works
and what it does and like hopefully he
won't die or retire this is kind of like
the world when you do Legacy
modernization so when I started getting
exposed to formal methods which is
primarily what the fault project is
about
um my first reaction to it was not what
people normally get really excited about
I don't give a if a system is
correct because when I'm dealing with
Cobalt from the 60s and then like
multiple layers of java piled on top of
it so we can slam some internet uh input
into the whole system I am willing to
stipulate that that system is not
correct right this is not a surprise to
me that this system is correct this is
not like a question of like can we
verify this system no it's wrong it's
all wrong right
and also the the this theory about like
formal methods using it to sort of
describe the specification when you go
before you go into implementation that's
wonderful but very rarely am I writing a
system from scratch usually I have
something already set out and I'm trying
to sort of incrementally improve it into
something better and there is some
degree of modeling that helps with that
but not really in the way the formal
methods Community advocates for if
you're thinking to yourself well like
why not just re-write it all from
scratch there's a great book you should
buy that explains exactly why you should
like just recommending like you should
just go into that right so the thing I
do care a lot about is reasoning about
systems particularly complex ones and
what their behaviors are what we think
their behaviors are what their behavior
should be and what their behavior
shouldn't be and formal method is
actually a really great tool for that
so I think a lot about this question as
of late how do people become experts in
systems because I do hear a lot that
there's this one guy who's like the
expert in the system and yeah of course
all of my clients are like it'd be great
if we had two guys who are the expert in
the system but we've been in this state
for like 20 years and we still haven't
figured out how to get a second guy up
to the same level of expertise so this
question of how people become experts
and how experts think about systems is
really relevant to the stuff that I do
and we actually know a lot about how
experts think about systems from
ergonomics and system safety and social
science so what an expert has that a
novice doesn't have or even an
intermediate user sometimes doesn't have
is this robust library of mental models
about what the system does and different
types of behaviors and different types
of
situations and context and when
something goes wrong on a system what
the expert does is kind of observe these
characteristics and try to match it to
the closest mental model in their head
and then they run these kind of
scenarios forward and backwards okay
this is the input I'm seeing what are
the outputs given that mental model or
they may go this is the output that I've
seen this is the failure I've seen given
the mental model what might have caused
that failure and this is how they do
these kind of Rapid deduction that we
all think is like magic and Wizardry
right
and so how do people build Mountain
models well we all know the answer to
this first of all you start with this
very thorough comprehensive
documentation that's wonderfully written
in plain language and then of course you
have a you've mocked out all your
dependencies and you have an amazing
development environment that you can run
locally that works exactly the way
production does and then you have a
robust Suite of tests integration tests
regression tests a unit tests so that
you can experimental behavior and like
make changes and all of that and like I
can tell by the laughter that like yeah
this isn't really how it works right
first of all we don't generally have
these things in real life software
engineering we aspire to them we don't
usually have them but even when we do
have them this isn't actually the way
people build mental models of systems
the way people actually build mental
models of systems is by operating
systems right so they spend some time
actually doing the work of like managing
the system and operating it and then
they have an incident and they panic and
freak out but the Panic is all the
learning coming into the body right so
I have never disliked being on incident
like being on call or being in a command
room because like there's so much I
learn about a system when something is
going wrong and like it's really it's
really a pleasant experience if you can
embrace it in the right way but this is
is how people actually build mental
models it's through operations
so a mental model is essentially a
pattern that we use as an analogy so a
great example of a kind of analogy that
we're talking about is a ship is to
water as a plane is to
thank you very much just to the air
right so if you understand the
relationship that a ship has in its
environment then you can make sort of
did some deductive conclusions about the
relationship the plane has in its
environment is it 100 accurate No but
does it get you to help you narrow
things down and sort of make some
general conclusions in an environment
you know nothing about yes so these are
the value of mental models we form these
patterns via abstraction and the part
that I found really fun is that we can
communicate those patterns and
abstractions via formal methods and
actually when you talk to people who are
really into the formal methods Community
this is one of the first things they'll
say that all the fancy like execution
and model checking is almost beside the
point you find a lot of the bugs and a
lot of the Insight just by trying to
write the model as specification in the
first place and having to go and talk to
people
so before we go deeper I don't want to
assume a baseline knowledge what do we
mean by formal methods does that mean we
all program in Bow Ties like what
exactly is the formal part of formal
methods and so the formal part we're
talking about is Boolean logic right we
were trying to prove for the properties
of a model mathematically using logic
and when we build a model we can use
that same model to sort of have
different levels of interaction we can
use it to run simulations we can use it
to check things and then we can use it
to do what's called execution but it's
slightly different than the execution
you might be thinking of
briefly simulation is a scenario where I
have a model I have inputs I give the
computer the inputs of the model and I
say give me the outputs show me what
happens when you have these inputs and
the computer can turn around and go okay
you've given me uh addition and you've
given me a two and you've given me a
three and obviously the answer is 5.
great
um because we're doing this with logic
we do not actually need to give the
computer any numbers at all we can give
them a set of variables and just say I
don't know whatever like it's addition
there's an a there's a b there's a c run
me a scenario in which like this is the
relationship and it can give you two
plus three but it can also say oh maybe
we want to think about one plus four
that also equals five right
so simulation in most cases uh is kind
of Overkill right if you all you want to
do is run a simulation you're probably
better off python because
um specifically in false case we're
dealing with smt models and those are MP
complete which means it is possible to
write a program that never returns an
answer ever so like probably there's a
lot of computational uh complexity there
and like if all you want to do is run a
simulation you're probably better off
just kind of doing it with a more
traditional programming language however
when you're writing a model to do
something more like checking more like
execution simulation just ends up being
really useful because it's our
equivalent of like the print statement
and the source code going like I
don't know what this I think this does
the right thing like please tell me if
I'm on the right path and so often we'll
just kind of like run it as a simulation
to see what the model Checker thinks
we've just expressed with our model
so then we get to checking so if
simulation is I give you the inputs and
you give me the output then checking is
I give you the output and you give me
the input so I have again I have this
relationship where a plus b equals c
um we're not equal C and I say I'm going
to get five and I'm going to stipulate
that there is no value for a and no
value for B that will ever equal C well
that's absurd and the computer very
quickly tells us no no no no there are
there are values for A and B what that
will equal five and here I can prove it
to you
and so again we don't actually need to
give the computer any numbers at all we
can just give them the relationship and
the variables and it will give us a
scenario in which the RN variance is uh
uh
uh Improvement and correct right and so
usually what we're doing here is that
this example sort of implies as we're
sort of saying to the computer I believe
that this is true about the system now
prove me wrong and the computer goes
challenge accepted we generally do it
with a little bit more complicated
things than addition
but this is what backs formal
verification so when people are talking
about formal verification they're
talking about this type of interaction
defining invariance and then having the
the model Checker kind of look for
conditions in with your invariants are
violated
um it's a good place to sort of clarify
that rarely are we talking about models
that represent the entire system we're
usually looking at specific interactions
and behaviors that we think should be
impossible on those specific
interactions
um and so it all this kind of of um
using the computer in this way sort of
helps us Focus deeply on the
requirements because we really have to
have these in-depth conversations about
what properties should be impossible in
the first place what behaviors should be
impossible and like why are they
impossible what about the system and the
way it operates makes these things
impossible
that brings us to symbolic execution so
we have uh simulation which is I give
you the inputs and the computer gives me
the outputs we have checking which is I
get the outputs and computer gives me
the inputs
symbolic execution is I give you the
inputs and the outputs and the computer
gives me the function that creates the
outputs from the inputs and so I will
tell the computer there is some function
for which two and three leads to five
and then computer will respond back
addition obviously if you add these two
things together you get your five and as
with the other examples we do not
actually need to think of the computer
any numbers at all it can just do this
based on variables
so this is kind of like fun Blackmagic
and typically when we build models like
this what we're actually doing is we're
defining every conceivable pathway
through a state graph or system and then
we're saying start from here go here
draw a line through all those Pathways
we use this a lot in malware analysis
and security engineering to figure out
can we break into this part of the
system through any particular channel uh
it's it's super super cool but kind of
difficult complex it's conceptualized
so kind of sum up some minor points
about logic here
um solvers tend to give you the first
answer they find in the state space
that's not necessarily the best or most
insightful answer it's just the one they
find first
um there are lots of really good options
that already exist in the formal methods
Community
um I use a lot of Z3 which is an smt
solver alloy TLA plus V forever
enter any interaction at all form
Investments these are probably somewhat
familiar to you at least by name if not
by playing around with them and that
leads to the question of like well well
then why would you write something new
especially since there's so much
academic Firepower on these really great
tools that already exist why do
something like fault
and so since I'm a person who works in
Old Computing systems a lot I tend to
sort of reference things back to
historical points and there was a point
in computer science where when you
complained about the syntax of computer
programs and how you didn't understand
what they did you got told well you're
just not good enough of a programmer you
should learn assembly and while this was
going on there was this momentum this
community of people who felt like
wouldn't it be great if like computer
programs were actually like readable by
human beings and comprehensible by human
beings and this is the high level
language movement that got going and we
know how that ended and like everything
that that we we do with computers today
is sort of of comes from this conflict
right if we were still writing assembly
we would not have iPhones we would not
have the vast majority of the
applications that we use on the internet
uh developing high-level languages that
allowed people to communicate with
computers in a way that was more
comfortable and intuitive to them sort
of opened the playing field up to a lot
of creative and innovative solutions and
I feel the same way about formal methods
the tools that currently exist their
syntax is very strongly tied back to the
mathematics in the same way assembly is
very strongly tied back to what the
actual computer is doing and that's
great but when you sort of say like hey
I don't understand what any of this
stuff means the response you sometimes
get from some people is like well if you
were serious about it you just learned
the math right and the most infuriating
thing is they go it's just high school
math
to which I sometimes say what high
school did you go to
but in any case
um I I thought like well what would
happen if we actually kind of created a
domain specific language that gave
people a little bit more of the
expressiveness that they think about
systems and then can pile down to smt
because computers can do that right we
can just compile down to what we wanted
to be in Boolean logic we don't need
people to to do a PhD in applied math on
the side
uh caveat here the math is really cool
right like I I do not want to discourage
anyone from actually going deep on
learning the actual math because that
has been a joy and pleasure for me the
last couple years is figuring out like
what exactly are these people talking uh
about so do please explore the math
because no one calling
but
um I kind of wanted I was kind of
curious about this idea of like what
would people write and what could we
write and what kind of reasoning could
we we what kind of conversations could
we have about the systems that we were
maintaining if we had an expressiveness
that was a little bit closer to how we
actually thought about systems
um especially given that both how people
uh reason about systems is so strongly
linked to how they try to express
themselves about them and also because
we know that the full benefits from this
type of modeling comes from
communication it comes from talking to
other people about what you think these
behaviors are so the more accessible our
expressiveness around these models are
the better we're going to get that
benefit from Communication in theory
Alice you'll tell me if you feel like
it's right at the end of it
so some facts about fault uh first of
all it's highly experimental which means
it breaks all the goddamn time uh it's
wonderful uh related namespace is the
demon like just really really hate the
new space
um it is technically not a compiler it
is technically a transpiler so what
fault is doing among other things it's a
domain-specific language and it's
compiling down to smt lib too uh which
means any solver that understands smt
can integrate with fault and can be used
to execute fall the small character
caveat there is that uh what I found out
when I switched it over from uh Z3 into
uses is that some solvers actually
format their results slightly
differently and so one of the things
fault does is it parses the results and
attempts to format it in a way that is a
little bit more comfortable as well and
so there's some testing and and
integration work that has to be done
there to make it like fully uh
cross-compatible across solvers but if
you can read smt you can have it just to
export the smt and run it on whatever
solver you like
um there's additional
stuff that I kind of added on top of the
logic because I work primarily in what
end up being either distributed systems
or web-based systems and um there's
stuff that we we care about in that
world that that isn't necessarily uh
doesn't map really nicely to logic
necessarily the first one being
probability like a lot of what I I work
on isn't really about is the system
correct it's about at what point does
the system fail and you can absolutely
write a model that will tell you like
this is the the breaking point in which
you transition from the state to this
other state that you've uh identified as
not not great
um but it'll often give you scenarios
that are just so outrageous given like
the day-to-day kind of data you see that
they seem unrealistic so it's useful to
have the the the compiler also be able
to tell you oh yeah and there's the nth
probability this will actually happen
um strings are booleans in fault and
we'll get to that in a second
um and then the output formatting ended
up being a really big deal and I would
say the vast majority of technical debt
on fault comes from me trying to figure
out how to format the output in a way
that made sense
so just summarizing it's a
domain-specific language it compiles
down to a single static assignment and
then ultimately to smt
uh it's syntax is C flavored curly
braces
semicolons I do love I do love my C
flavored languages uh it's base
abstraction the first one I started with
is the stock flow model which is from
System Dynamics
uh it uses State charts as well again
strings are booleans more on that in a
second there are no lists no sets no
maps for now
um I realized that from the perspective
of first order logic saying there are no
sets in my formal methods is essentially
heresy and so if you see someone
stacking up some logs around a wooden
stake later on in the afternoon that
that's for me
um but it just at the time it felt like
let's keep it simple let's not let's not
have collections of any kind let's just
keep things in a relatively simple
pattern
so hitting on this like what is a stock
full model so this is this idea of
thinking about feedback loops as a
matter of pools of resources and then
functions that uh affect some sort of
change on the pools of resource and so
your stocks are your polls of resources
and then your flows are the rates these
functions that are essentially
implementing change upon your resources
so from a technical point of view we can
think of resources being like system
memory system storage CPU and then we
can think of it various functions that
increase or decrease that in our system
uh memory allocation creating files and
data starting processes so on and so
forth then we also have a different set
of functions that free them up right the
garbage collection we have deleting
files we have terminating processes so
we can think about how our VMS are
reacting and interacting with one
another in this way of like pools of
resources and then functions acting on
those pools for resources
and then maybe we might build a model
like this where we have like a queue of
files and for every file we pull off the
queue it triggers an allocation of
memory so we can process it and then we
have some sort of defined Heap size that
when the memory gets to a certain point
it triggers garbage collection so this
is an example of a type of model we
might write with like stocks inflows
and so this kind of format is a bit
different than what you mostly find in
formal methods because again we're not
thinking about correctness so much as
we're thinking about interactions and
capacity and how that creates Behavior
it's essentially an extension of control
theory uh the people who develop System
Dynamics they wanted to apply the same
rigor control theory but they couldn't
really quantify on things they couldn't
really quantify like business practices
so they had a sense of like it gets
bigger it gets smaller but they didn't
really have like actual numbers for
rates of change on this and this was a
way of sort of getting the same sort of
rigor without having to quantify
everything
um and you can express a lot of
different types of systems using the
subtractions sort of where I started was
like the base of how I wanted to build
my models and this is what it looks like
in in fault so we have we're going to
Define our abstractions we're going to
define a stock and then we're going to
define a a flow and then we're going to
say that these two abstractions are
connected together and Within These
flows we have we Define the functions of
actually how we change them right
and then we have a uh what's called a
run Block in which we sort of initialize
the model we say we've defined all these
attractions these are the ones we're
using for these abstractions and then
within that run block we're defining
these steps of the model so in addition
to having no sets no lists and and no
Maps fault doesn't have a while loop or
a for Loop because it's a bounded Loop
model so the whole model is itself a
loop it runs a number of times and it
follows these steps and it looks at
whether you ever invalidate a constraint
in the course of the model so this this
particular model would run for four
rounds and every single round it would
repeat the logic within the Run lock
so before we get into the details of
that I want to briefly cover what is
single static assignment because it kind
of becomes a tiny bit important here so
assuming that uh you all know nothing
about compiler single static assignment
is this idea of variables are
essentially immutable static we don't
change their value after we assign them
so what do we do we want to change the
value of a variable well we create a new
variable and we put the value of the new
Vari in the new variable so if we have a
variable a and we set it to four and
then we want to change it later to 6 we
say okay the value of a 1 is now a 0
plus 2 right and so this is single
static assignment it's done in compiles
or compilers and it's actually really
useful in smt because SNT really likes
like we have a variable and you only
have to tell you what its value is once
and so when we compile the uh model I
just showed you this is part of what
fault generates on the smt side so yes
smt is in Polish notation
are we all comfortable with Polish
notation
okay a couple hands go yes some of us
have like lost weekends with lisp I get
it it's fun but for those of you who
never had a good time with list I feel
sorry for you the only thing you need to
understand about polish notation is it's
just a change in the order that you're
used to so you're used to the operator
being in the middle of A and B and post
notation we pull it out in front and
then the the parameters are afterwards
so in our run block we have this weird
pipe operator because this is what we
call an uh System Dynamics a bathtub
model and the bathtub model is like the
hello world of System Dynamics when they
want to explain what System Dynamics is
to people they draw a bathtub model the
idea being your resource is a bath tell
your um stock is a bathtub and then you
have a flow of a faucet bringing water
into the bathtub and a drain bringing
water out of the bathtub and the model
question because does the bathtub
overflow right well
in a bathtub in the scenario of running
the faucet and we're running the drain
it is not step one we fill the bathtub
up with water step two we drain the
bathtub of water these things are
happening at the same time
um which is somewhat complicated to do
in logic but what we're saying here with
this pipe operator is that these two
processes are running in parallel we do
not know which one completes first and
so what fold does is it does scenario
one scenario one is that the water
coming out is moving at a faster rate
than the water coming in and so this
completes first and the water completely
coming in complete second and the
scenario two is the opposite the water
coming in completes before the water
coming out so this happens first and
then the water comes out and so
obviously in the design of these flows
them to kind of smaller you can keep
them the closer you get to like
simulating actual concurrency
and then we have this lovely statement
in which we're saying to the smt solver
great we have two potential outcomes at
the end of this pick one don't care
which figure out which one it is right
and the important thing here is this
water level five this is what's called a
Phi value and when you're using single
static assignment you have any kind of
branching logic whether it be uh choices
between two parallel processes like this
or more likely an if conditional you are
going to have variables change within
that conditional block you're going to
be incrementing that count in single
static assignment and then you're going
to come out of that block and whether or
not you took that Branch or not you're
now out of sync on your account so the
Phi value is the next iteration that
where you basically say whatever we
ended up with dump that value in this
five value so their count has evened out
and normalized and we can move on this
is actually a lot simpler in smt because
we're asking the solver to make all
those choices for us then it is an
actual compilers but que sera
all right so if when we run this model
this is what Z3 returns right so I run
this model and it's like great success
here are your results and this is a lot
of why the fault does so much processing
on the actual like output side because
there are a couple things that are
really difficult about reading this
first of all the results are completely
out of order uh for the variable
definitions and they can be in any order
that uh that Z3 feels like at the time
so you kind of have to hunt around to
sort of see how variables are changing
and then the other thing is that
sometimes it'll return Expressions
instead of values so this one's not so
bad because all it's doing is saying
it's negative 15 so it's expressing it
as 15 and then a minus operator but it
will actually return fractions sometimes
and those become very difficult to just
sort of eyeball and figure out like well
what exactly is that value that's been
returned
and so it became very clear very quickly
that this simple like writing of the
model and then compiling down to smt was
not actually enough to build something
useful I had to be able to parse the
results and then figure out how to
express them in ways that were useful to
people
um and so there were a couple different
things that I went through in that quest
uh the first of which being the easiest
which is just taking all of the state
changes first putting them in the right
order grouping them by the variable they
they related to and then just putting
them in kind of like a list okay this is
how this variable changes throughout the
model but very quickly the the it became
very obvious that this took situations
where there were branches where there
were parallel things going on it just
flattened them out and didn't give you
any insight about which one of them
actually relevant in the scenario or
what was happening or anything like that
so this became very clear it was not
going to work and so the second thing I
tried was actually visualizing it
because I am a huge fan of alloy and
allies great visualization of models so
like let's take a shot of what that
looks like and so this is an output into
mermaid.js and there are lots of
advantages now we see the branching
logic is a much clearer
um and we know what the Phi values are
but it doesn't actually show where the
violation is and also I had really
complicated feelings about something
that runs on the command line
essentially just spitting out a bunch of
mermaid.js that I guess you then copy
and paste and like go to the web browser
to look at so I felt like that that
doesn't work and I wasn't really into
building an entire like IDE for my pet
programming language so I moved on and I
thought you know
what if we made it look like an event
log and so this is what it currently
outputs by default where it tells you
how the solver is initialized all the
variables and then it also tells you
where that state change happens within
the model it gives you kind of the scope
is this something that happens in the
global scope or is this something that's
happening in a particular function
um it also then filters out the dead
branches so the ones that were not
selected we don't really need to know
about those State changes because they
have effectively not happened so it then
cleans it up in that way and then this
makes it much easier to sort of read
through in sort of visualize what the
scenario is actually describing to you
is
so how much time do I have left oh good
I have enough time I thought it would be
fun do you guys want to see and play
with some more models
that was the right answer
all right I think that's a good size on
uh on text right everybody can see
ever been the first five rows if you're
sitting further back just move up I
don't get it so I want to go back to
this statement I made that like strings
and faults are booleans right because
the reality of it is that anything that
can be expressed in binary you you can
express in uh smt right because it's
Boolean logic but
doing string manipulation with logic
programming is sort of like I don't know
what the point would be I'm sure there's
some amazing dissertation that explains
to me what the point of that would be
but I don't know what it is and so
please forward the paper to me so I can
learn but there is something that I
thought was really useful which is when
you're defining these kind of static
rules it's really nice to have kind of
long-form descriptions of what that
static rule represents so this is what I
use strings how I repurpose strings is
that they are effectively treated and
interpreted as booleans but I allow them
to be defined as strings so that it's
really clear to the human being that's
reading the not the the model exactly
what that rule represents and so what
you're looking at here is a model I did
of the White House's directive that all
uh federal employees be vaccinated for
covid-19
and the reason why I chose this is two
first of all executive orders tend to be
relatively uh short and compact
um and they have few dependencies so
this particular executive order is
dependent on two other pieces of
Regulation both of in the U.S code the
first one defining what a federal agency
is and the second one defining what a
federal employee is
um if you have had an experience with
policy then you will know that the
dependency Tree on an average piece of
Regulation would mean node package
manager Cry tears of joy right like we
we put we put node projects to shame
with our dependency trees so they get
very complicated and people get very
confused by them
and so this is an example of uh how I
might Express the definition of what an
agency is and I now can import that into
my model and I can say okay I assert
that everybody who is classified as a
federal employee must also be vaccinated
for covid-19 enough caps lock is on okay
and so now I'm going to ask fault and
I'm not going to screw up my typing
to run this model and I'm actually going
to run it in a specific format for
static rules because then it'll make it
pretty
okay so then what fault puts out is
because it's a static model it will
essentially print out all of the string
values and then tell me if those rules
are true
there's a lot going on here so it says I
have found a row of a scenario in which
covid vaccination and employment status
are not uh not equal the same thing and
what's funny about this is that I
thought it would give me a scenario in
which you didn't have to be vaccinated
for covid it says no be vaccinated for
Cova just don't work for the government
and then everything's fine
so and I I feel judged by my language
compiler a little bit as the person
who's done a fair amount of work for the
government but another fun thing that
you can find when you start looking
through what is true in this model is
there are all sorts of fun weird things
in government regulations so let's see
if I can highlight it yeah okay so here
as it turns out did you know that the
U.S Navy used to own a dairy farm
they don't anymore but if you were an
employee of that dairy farm before they
sold it like you you may or may not be
considered a government employee I think
you are considered a government employee
so it kind of helps you find like these
strange edge cases uh within these kind
of scenarios
but you know let's go back to like
actual technical stuff that's that's
cute and amusing and so I'm gonna pull
up this one which is an example of a
state machine I talked about fault does
State charts and this was I think one of
the most valuable pieces of Syntax for
me as a person in model systems was
deciding to do state charts and so what
this is is kind of like a system for
buying and selling tickets like
Ticketmaster and I've defined a seat as
having three states it's either free for
you to buy a ticket uh to sit in it it's
on hold because you're in the process of
buying it and or it's sold right and so
I can now take this state chart and
within each state I Define the
conditions and logic that determine
where it moves to once it's in that
state so from free it can advance to
being on hold and from on hold it can
advance to either going back to free
because it changed my mind or it can
advance to going sold and from there I
can now make a assertions about the pass
through this state chart
and so oh no what did I just do
okay
and so we can run this
[Music]
song
and what it's going to tell us is that
it has found no case in which our
invariant has been violated excellent
great so it does this because I have an
assert statement which means that I'm
checking instead of running simulations
if I take out if I comment out the
assert statement and run it again it'll
then give me a scenario it was like okay
this is the thing that could happen in
your state chart you could transition
here and here and here and here and here
and so that's all fun and cool but
um not particularly useful so let's add
a little bit more complexity to it what
if click this in okay great
for a second I was worried he was going
to shut down the whole editor what if we
started to bring in a little sense of
time because realistic speaking when we
do these kind of uh ticket sites right
you can't be on hold you can't be
holding a seat forever right you have a
certain window of opportunity which you
can transition from on hold to sold or
you lose the seat and so we're going to
use the stock flow construction to
create a sense of time we have a
reservoir of a certain number of minutes
and then we have a timer that ticks down
those minutes every time that function
uh is hit and then from there we go back
and we have a very similar state chart
to what we already had except we changed
some of the logic on the on hold and we
say okay check to see the timer
uh if it's less than or equal to zero it
can only advance to free you got to free
up that seat uh if it's not then it can
either stay where it is or it can
advance to to sold right and then we can
Define assertions based on the behavior
of this model
and now when we run this one I'm just
going to change the two
it finds a scenario in which that's not
true and so it defines the value of
um our pool of resources as being
exactly one minute with exactly one
round and then it says well there's if
you start from the state of a free seat
there's absolutely no way for you to get
out of being on hold in that one minute
that we've allotted per round
so
I think I have time for one more
and so I have two options we can either
go back to the bathtub mode model and
look at a bug that I found in the
compiler or we can talk about dependency
graphs
bug or dependencies
oh man all right you guys don't want to
see my bugs what's wrong with this this
is like I'm on stage prone to be
humiliated and you all don't want to see
my bugs all right fine we'll do
dependencies so this is a uh something
I've been playing around with recently
because I kind of really want to do
Boolean lattices and so I've been
looking at how do we do different types
of graphs can we express different types
of graphs right so I'm going to start
from
um the specification what I did is I
took a list of dependencies think of
this as your requirements text and I
basically created this stock called node
where we have all the dependencies that
we could be using in this project and
then from there I have
um the the actual instances of each node
in which I say okay this is a node now
these are the dependencies that are
turned on and what I can do from here is
now create insertions about what things
are turned on and active in the system
at what times
so I see people like I can hear the
rumbling of crowds moving so I'm going
to end it there I'm going to say that
fault is open source and on GitHub you
will probably break it if you use it but
that's excellent just send me this spec
that broke it and I will then go fix it
and thank you so much for your time guys
I'm more than happy to take questions if
you find me later
[Applause]